nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir
Madame Élisabeth borne première ministre
madame la Première ministre je tiens à
le dire d'emblée je crois que c'est la
troisième fois que vous êtes auditionné
par une commission d'enquête sous cette
mandature je crois aussi que c'est
complètement inédit sous la 5e
République un premier ministre en
exercice soit auditionné de façon aussi
régulière c'était à la fois un signe de
vitalité démocratique pour le Parlement
mais aussi je crois qu'il faut vous en
remercier de vous prêter à cet exercice
car cela représente pour vous et pour
vos équipes une charge de travail non
négligeable que nous ne sous-estimons
pas
la première ministre vous avez consacré
une grande partie de votre vie
professionnelle et puis de votre vie
publique au développement des transports
publics dans notre pays et c'est
essentiellement sur la période où vous
avez exercé la responsabilité de
ministres chargés des transports de 2017
à fin 2019 que nos questions vont devoir
vont
se consacrer sachant que nous avons fait
le choix de auditionner systématiquement
l'ensemble des ministre des Transports
depuis 1995 dans notre pays avec sur
cette commission d'enquête de l'angle
particuliers l'un d'essayer de
comprendre les raisons qui ont amené à
la régression jusqu'à une date récente
de la part modale du frais de
ferroviaire en France et l'autre de
pencher plus spécifiquement sur les
effets de la libéralisation du fret à
partir de 2006
sur cette cette évolution de la part
modale et sur la situation financière de
fret SNCF madame la Première ministre
sous votre autorité au ministère des
Transports il y a eu bien évidemment
deux textes très importants qui ont
dessiné le paysage des transports
d'aujourd'hui d'une part la loi portant
nouveau pacte ferroviaire en 2018 et
c'est essentiellement de celle-ci que
nous parlerons avec la le nouveau dessin
d'ailleurs le nouveau projet du groupe
public ferroviaire organisé en société
anonyme désormais et non plus en épique
et des conséquences qu'il a pu avoir sur
l'activité de SNCF les débats aussi à ce
moment sur la reprise de cette dette de
SNCF dont on sait que c'est l'un des
objets de l'enquête approfondie qui a
été lancé par l'Union européenne le 18
janvier 2023 et puis cette cette période
que vous avez connu au ministère des
Transports c'est aussi une période où le
risque contentieux qui n'avait pas le
même visage qu'aujourd'hui mais était
déjà potentiellement déclaré avec les
plaintes qui avaient été déposées en
2016 d'abord par un puis par plusieurs
des concurrents de fret SNCF contre le
soutien public à cette entreprise dans
un secteur concurrentiel et donc
l'un des objets de cette audition c'est
aussi d'échanger avec vous sur la
manière dont vous évaluez à cette époque
le risque de contentieux et puis
évidemment un moment où pendant deux ans
et demi vous avez beaucoup mis la
question des mobilités du quotidien et
mobilité voyageurs du quotidien au
premier plan de vos prises de parole et
de vos actions
des sujets pour nous sera également de
comprendre comment vous envisagiez à
cette époque dans les politiques
publiques dont vous aviez la
responsabilité la politique d'État de
soutien au fret dont je rappelle qu'elle
a abouti en 2021 au lancement de la
stratégie nationale de développement du
frais de ferroviaire qui a déjà produit
un certain nombre d'effets sur le
redressement de la part modale et le
redressement de la situation des
finances de fret SNCF et puis madame la
Première ministre je me doute aussi que
qu'un certain nombre d'entre nous vous
questionnerons sur les discussions en
cours même si nous avons déjà eu avec la
Commission européenne un échange très
approfondi de 2h30 avec le ministre
chargé des transports Clément Baule je
vous laisserai la parole madame la
Première ministre pour une intervention
luminaire d'une quinzaine de minutes à
la suite de quoi nous poursuivrons nos
échanges sur la forme de questions et de
réponses vous le savez puisque c'est
déjà la troisième fois
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires prévoit
que les personnalités auditionnées
quelque soit leur qualité doivent prêter
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité et rien que la vérité je vais
donc vous demander de lever la main
droite et de bien vouloir dire je le
jure
je vous en remercie madame la Première
ministre et donc je vous donne la parole
pour une quinzaine de minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés comme vous l'avez rappelé vous
avez souhaité moditionner au titre de
mes anciennes fonctions de ministres des
Transports de mai 2017 à juillet 2019 je
me réjouis d'ailleurs de voir que vous
avez reçu un grand nombre de mes
prédécesseurs et successeur ainsi que
les personnes directement en charge du
dossier du dossier Fret SNCF aujourd'hui
conformément à votre convocation c'est
donc bien en cette qualité d'ancienne
ministre des Transports que je suis
présente aujourd'hui et que je répondrai
à vos interrogations
d'autant plus que le ministre délégué
chargé des transports Clément Beaune que
votre commission à d'ores et déjà
auditionné a pu détailler avec une
grande précision les décisions de mon
gouvernement et leurs implications
avant de répondre à vos questions
j'aimerais revenir quelques instants sur
notre politique en matière de frais de
ferroviaire et sur les contexte de la
création de fret SNCF
d'abord je voudrais rappeler que le
frais de ferroviaire est un atout pour
notre économie et notre planification
écologique c'est un mode de transport à
la fois bien moins émetteur de CO2 que
le camion et qui ne s'ajoutent pas au
trafic routier
pourtant ces dernières années le frais
de ferroviaire a connu un lourd déclin
passant de 52 milliards de tonnes en
2000 à 35 milliards en 2017 et d'une
part modale de 20% à 10% en 2017
également
les raisons de cette baisse sont
nombreuses notamment la concurrence du
mode routier plus agile et devenu plus
compétitif en particulier parce que le
financement de son infrastructure la
route ne pèse que très peu sur lui
j'ajoute que la désindustrialisation de
notre pays ces dernières décennies a
également eu un impact sur la baisse du
du trafic de frais de ferroviaire
au-delà de ces raisons extérieures le
fret a aussi a aussi perdu en intérêt du
fait du sous-investissement dont tu as
fait l'objet notre réseau
l'âge moyen du réseau est d'environ 30
ans presque le double de celui de nos
voisins et ce constat est encore plus
visible sur les petites lignes de frais
de ferroviaire dans la moyenne d'âge et
de l'ordre de 70 ans
en 2017 le frais de ferroviaire était
donc dans une situation critique
et décède date le gouvernement a décidé
d'agir pour que le frais de ferroviaire
redevienne une filière d'avenir
je pense d'abord à deux lois du
précédent quinquennat que vous avez
évoqué qui ont contribué à la relance de
cette filière la loi d'orientation des
mobilités et le nouveau pacte
ferroviaire de texte que j'ai porté
comme ministre
ces deux textes ont été conçus avec une
double exigence une exigence
environnementale d'abord car je le
disais le ferroviaire et notre meilleur
atout pour décarboner des transports et
une exigence d'efficacité ensuite car le
succès d'une telle politique passe par
une filière compétitive
la réforme de 2018 a permis de
réaffirmer le statut public de la SNCF
tout en lui donnant une structure
moderne où les rôles de chaque entité
ont été clarifiés nous avons également
agi pour assainir les finances de la
SNCF 35 milliards de dettes ont été
repris par l'État à la SNCF et des
cibles de redressement ont été donnés à
l'entreprise notre objectif éviter que
la situation de surendettement dans le
réseau ferré national a été le premier à
souffrir ne se reproduise
grâce à cette réforme et aux efforts de
l'État les finances du groupe ont été
assainies malgré les impacts de la crise
covid et de la guerre en Ukraine la SNCF
a dégagé en 2022 des flux de trésorerie
positifs et le groupe a résorbé sa dette
j'ajoute que cette réussite est la clé
des succès futurs du frais de
ferroviaire public c'est ce qui lui
permettra d'investir dans son réseau et
dans ses activités stratégiques
s'agissant de fret SNCF l'entreprise a
été créée au 1er janvier 2020 dans sa
forme actuelle cette activité étant
auparavant une partie de l'établissement
public SNCF mobilité là encore la
réforme ferroviaire apporté ses fruits
en créant cette société nous avons
modernisé son fonctionnement c'était
nécessaire notamment pour lui permettre
de gagner des parts de marché car je le
rappelle le frais de ferroviaire est
devenu concurrentiel en 2007 soit bien
avant la réforme ferroviaire que j'ai
portée
un objectif majeur après l'idée ou choix
fait au moment de la constitution de la
société
garantir une viabilité à fêter SNCF et
lui permettre de revenir à l'équilibre
financier nous avons atteint cet
objectif dès 2021 l'entreprise a dégagé
une marge opérationnelle positive pour
la première fois depuis 10 ans
cette transformation est donc une
réussite pour le groupe SNCF pour sa
filiale de fret et plus largement pour
la bonne utilisation des deniers publics
dans le prolongement de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités l'État s'est
ensuite doté d'une stratégie nationale
pour le développement du frais de
ferroviaire dès 2021
là encore nous avons poursuivi un
objectif simple
mener des investissements nécessaires
pour enrayer le déclin du frais de
ferroviaire et doubler la part modale du
ferroviaire de 9 à 18%. cet objectif a
d'ailleurs été réaffirmé dans la loi
climat et résilience en 2021
ainsi nous avons déployé des moyens
financiers importants pour moderniser le
réseau ou aider les segments de marché
en concurrence avec la route et
structurellement déficitaire
mais pas seulement nous avons aussi pris
des mesures pour donner une meilleure
place aux fraises qu'il ne soit plus
perçu comme la variable d'ajustement du
secteur par exemple lorsqu'il y a des
travaux ou lors de l'attribution des
sillons
ce travail aucun gouvernement ne l'avait
mené avant nous et il a permis de
redresser la barre le réseau c'est
moderniser et la part modale du fret a
cessé son érosion et a même malgré la
crise covid commencez à se redresser
passant au dessus des 10%
nous avons donc amorcé le renouveau du
frais de ferroviaire mais ce travail est
loin d'être achevé pour accélérer nous
poursuivons la modernisation du réseau
ferré avec le plan d'avenir pour les
transports issus des travaux du Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures que
vous présidez monsieur le Président
ce plan je le rappelle ce sont 100
milliards d'euros d'investissements pour
le ferroviaire d'ici 2040 avec une
importante composante de modernisation
de régénération du réseau et
d'investissement rien que pour la
décennie à venir ce plan prévoit 4
milliards d'euros pour le frais de
ferroviaire dans la moitié portée par
l'État
vous le voyez nous réinvestissons
pleinement sur la filière du frais de
ferroviaire avec une volonté politique
claire des moyens financiers ambitieux
et une visibilité sur plusieurs années
pour atteindre notre objectif de
doublement de la part modale
mesdames et messieurs les députés ces
efforts seraient toutefois 20 si Fred
SNCF de loin le premier opérateur de
Fred ferroviaire venait à disparaître
c'est pourquoi nous avons pris les
devants avec le groupe SNCF pour
sécuriser l'avenir économique de
l'entreprise
étant auditionné au titre de mes
anciennes fonctions de ministres je ne
reviendrai pas sur le détail de la
discontinuité ou sur les négociations
menées avec la Commission européenne
elles vous ont été expliquées par le
ministre délégué lors de son audition je
souhaite seulement réaffirmer les
principes qui ont guidé l'action de mon
gouvernement
nous n'acceptons pas de jouer à la
roulette russe l'avenir de fret SNCF ni
celui de ses salariés il ne s'agit pas
de dire que ce plan est indolore c'est
une transformation importante pour fêter
SNCF et ses salariés mais c'est une
transformation qui préserve une
cohérence d'activité une pleine
intégration au sein du groupe SNCF et
l'identité publique de la nouvelle
entité
loin de revenir sur nos objectifs
d'augmentation de la part modale du
frais de ferroviaire cette structure
vise à pérenniser et à développer le
fret en France c'est donc une solution
d'équilibre une solution raisonnable
d'une part elle peut permettre d'éviter
le remboursement d'une aide d'État qui
signerait l'arrêt de mort de fret SNCF
d'autre part elle garantira la
préservation intégrale du cœur de métier
de l'entreprise je vous remercie
merci madame la Première ministre de
deux questions pour commencer et avant
de donner la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur
l'une d'abord vous avez évoqué le
caractère inédit de la stratégie
nationale de développement du frais de
ferroviaire lancé en 2021 et dont en
effet le principe se trouvait écrit dans
la loi d'orientation des mobilités de
comme vous le savez sur cette politique
publique il y a eu un empilement de plan
et de stratégie successives je pense
notamment à l'engagement national pour
le frais de ferroviaire en 2009 et aux
conférences périodiques sur le fret
ferroviaire lancé en 2013 par Frédéric
Cuvillier comment expliquer vous l'échec
de ces politiques successives d'une part
à améliorer la part modale du frais de
ferroviaire et d'autre part à redresser
la barre de fret SNCF qui sont deux
sujets assez différents
puis deuxième question sur ce risque
contentieux les premières plaintes
effectivement ont été déposées en 2016 à
l'époque où votre prédécesseur à
l'individus était ministre délégué au
transport mais elles étaient donc
pendantes au moment où vous étiez en
activité au ministère des Transports
quels étaient les contacts ou les
échanges que vous pouviez avoir avec la
Commission européenne à cette époque ou
avec Fret SNCF et où des chargeurs pour
essayer de
[Musique]
disons de d'envisager cette situation de
manière à donner à un maximum de
visibilité au secteur le paysage qui
nous a été brossé hier par Jean-Pierre
farandoux de cet évaluation du risque
était celui de quelque chose qui était
jusque là dans le paysage mais dont le
niveau de risque était jugé malgré tout
assez faible et que malgré tout ce qui
s'est passé en janvier a été considéré
comme un choc par l'entreprise publique
et puis ce que ce qui nous a également
été avancés hier je crois que c'était
par Guillaume Pepy c'est que
les plaintes déposées en 2016 étaient de
son point de vue essentiellement destiné
à obtenir que la France engagea des
politiques publiques de soutien aux
frais de ferroviaire qui soit comparable
pour l'ensemble du secteur à ce qui
était engagé pour SNCF fret voilà
comment évaluer vous comment évaluer
vous à cette époque le risque
contentieux et qu'elles échangent
avez-vous eu sur ce sujet
alors sur votre première question
pourquoi les plans antérieurs n'avaient
pas porté leurs fruits je pense que il y
a certainement un certain nombre de
causes structurelles
qui n'avaient pas été prise à bras le
corps comme on a pu le faire depuis je
pense notamment à l'état du réseau ferré
et je pense qu'on peut tous constater
que effectivement depuis 2017
en accompagnement de la réforme de la
SNCF on a enfin progressivement mis à
niveau des investissements de remise en
état du réseau et je pense qu'il y
aurait un paradoxe à imaginer qu'on peut
avoir une activité performante sur un
réseau qui lui-même a des performances
qui se détériorent au fil des années
donc je j'ai pas de doute que les
investissements très important dans le
réseau qui vont encore s'accentuer sur
les années qui viennent sont une des
leviers indispensables pour permettre un
redressement du frais de ferroviaire
je pense qu'il y a aussi
difficulté je les dise liée à la
désindustrialisation c'est certain que
dans un pays qui a perdu des centaines
de milliers voire plus de 1 million un
million et demi d'emplois sur une
décennie industrielle
évidemment c'est le marché même du frais
de ferroviaire qui est en attrition et
ça complique évidemment largement le
positionnement de l'activité de fret
ferroviaire
je pense aussi que
c'est un peu à l'image globalement du
groupe SNCF le fait d'être plombé par
une dette qui finit par faire perdre des
repères y compris dans le la gestion et
le pilotage économique de l'entreprise
et aussi un élément qui voilà le manque
de le manque de de
visibilité finalement sur ce que pouvait
être l'avenir de l'activité à
certainement on a certainement pas
contribué à
soutenir un plan de redressement de ce
frais de ferroviaire
et puis peut-être je peux ajouter aussi
puisque c'est des sujets qui ont été
largement évoqués dans la stratégie qui
a été mise en œuvre à partir de 2021
évidemment les travaux sur le réseau
sont nécessaires en même temps il
constitue aussi un handicap important
pour l'activité de frais de ferroviaire
si les travaux se font au détriment de
l'activité elle-même donc c'est
l'ensemble de ces éléments à la fois la
réindustrialisation que nous avons
engagé depuis 2017 la régénération du
réseau la priorisation de sillons de
qualité pour le frais de ferroviaire et
le
désendettement de cette activité est la
possibilité d'avoir une trajectoire
économique soutenable qui constitue je
pense des leviers importants pour
réussir là où ça n'avait pas été le cas
dans le cadre des plans précédents
pour revenir à votre question sur les
plaintes effectivement elles étaient
dans le paysage lorsque j'étais ministre
ce n'était pas non plus le la seule
situation de ce type en Europe et c'est
vrai que la Commission ne s'était pas
encore saisie de ces plaintes donc on
n'avait pas une acuité comme elle a pu
intervenir après que la Commission a
ouvert sa procédure je voilà je pense
qu'effectivement le déclenchement de
cette procédure appelé des mesures
notamment celles qui ont pu être
décrites par le ministre pour assurer
pour sécuriser l'avenir de fret SNCF et
c'est bien ce qui a été mené depuis
merci la première ministre je vous parle
passe la parole à Monsieur le rapporteur
bienvenue
la première ministre pour cette
disponibilité
nous n'en disposerons pas visiblement
tout du moins à 7h de la part de la
commissaire européenne
mais donc c'est un peu un point qui doit
être souligné
je vous interrogerai
sur la grande focale 2017 jusqu'à ce
jour puisque vous êtes ministre des
Transports
2017-2019 puis ensuite titulaire
ministère de l'Écologie et aujourd'hui
première ministre
2016 oui dès 2016 cette épée de Damoclès
tout de même de des plaintes et de la
Commission européenne et sur notre tête
et
nous entrons progressivement dans le
débat de 2018 du pacte ferroviaire
et
c'est un débat important mobilisé le
gouvernement une transformation
significative bien évidemment
du groupe de l’épique en
vous avez
sous réserve que
confirmer était amené à déclarer
dans les débats parlementaires
qui ont l'occasion que la nouvelle
organisation de de fret SNCF et ça
freine donc
était validé de manière heureux
compatible en quelque sorte et que les
garanties nécessaires avaient été prises
auprès de la des autorités européennes
[Musique]
le prélèvement de la dette
aurait de fait
fausser la lecture de la rentabilité
économique de l'activité telle que
vous veniez de décider de ça création
d'où leur envoie de ma question
confirmez-vous avoir ou non
vérifiez le recompatibilité de la
création de la SA en fonction de l'état
du contentieux à cette date auprès de la
Commission européenne et
considérez-vous ou niez-vous le fait que
vous avez porté sur le marché en créant
cette et ça et bien dans les standards
des règles et bien du libéralisme une
société effectivement non viable c'est
ma première question
nous avons été amenés par ailleurs
à
vérifier que
selon les propos d'un certain nombre de
responsables de la SNCF
que sommes toutes et bien cette
transformation en SA à l'occasion de la
loi donc de 2018 et de son application
progressive
et bien
aurait pu être considéré de la part de
les de l'exécutif français comme ayant
soldée
les pittes d'un mot clés de la
discontinuité était
dans les années nous l'a confirmé
monsieur Djebari de ces années quand
même un élément de débat
or
aurait été elle était soldée que la
Commission européenne aurait indiqué
nous vous autorisons allez vers la
création de cet de cet état bien
évidemment mais nous y reviendrons
nous y reviendrons au
contentieux ouvert donc dès les plantes
de 2016
confirmer mais vous cette
ce désappointement qui aurait pu être
celui de votre Ministre des Transports
et de vous-même donc au titre de
ministère de tutelle devant une telle
remarque de la Commission
européenne troisième élément
la France préside l'Union européenne du
1er janvier
1er semestre dirait 2022
porte d'ailleurs
au terme même des propos de la stratégie
développement du frais de Ferrière porte
auprès de la Commission européenne
et bien un enjeu majeur pour notre pays
qui est qui est le fret le disons et
nous constatons
dans les propos liés de Monsieur le
Directeur et bien que dès la clôture
quasiment de la présidence française
c'est-à-dire dès l'automne 2022 soudain
un durcissement de ton
se perd
nous dit-il de la part de la Commission
européenne qui
en gros porte lucase
d'une possible ouverture de
une commission d'enquête
il le dit en s'interrogeant nous
mesurons pas le pourquoi du comment de
se durcissement brutal de
ton et
de l'engagement de la Commission
européenne à l'encontre donc de fret
SNCF alors que les plaintes ont été
élevées etc avez-vous sur ce point une
réponse au pourquoi
du président directeur qui nous l'a
exprimé hier après-midi
y a-t-il dirais-je
un élément de marché
comme
comme nos interlocuteurs l'a évoqué
est-ce que le fret SNCF en France dans
notre pays a été l'objet d'un marché
politique
certains évoquent le nucléaire d'autres
politiques agricole commune question je
vous la pose en toute en toute
transparence
enfin il y a une remarque et j'en
terminerai monsieur le Président il y a
une remarque ce matin qui en fait
éclairé la question terminale que je
vous poserai
la France n'est pas le seul pays à avoir
son impérateur historique
interrogé sur les conditions de son
financement
et en particulier donc l'Allemagne
et la question quand nous interlocuteurs
se posait ce matin c'est que
au vu de l'enjeu écologique que vous
portez depuis
nombreuses années vous-même au vu de
l'enjeu écologique et de l'urgence
en matière de changement climatique
comment d'un point de vue politique je
dis bien politique donc je vous renvoie
à la voix de la France et à la fois
d'autres pays importants au niveau de
l'Union européenne comment se fait-il
qu'il n'y ait pas eu à minimal option
ce qui semble-t-il n'a pas été fait
de l'ouverture d'un dialogue commun pour
être clair entre la France et
l'Allemagne
pour promouvoir dans cette séquence je
dirais
délicate avec la Commission européenne
tendue
ministre du gibari dirait dans un bras
de fer qui se poursuivait et se
durcissait comment se fait-il donc qu'un
dialogue n'est pas été inauguré entre
nos deux pays voire plus avant bien
évidemment puisque d'autres pays de
l'Union européenne sont confrontés à ce
type de procédure pour et bien à un
moment donné faire politiquement
prévaloir
y compris dans le moyen terme
et bien
l'intérêt
de l'écologie et de l'urgence écologique
par rapport aux enjeux d'une concurrence
étroite
telle que conduite par Bruxelles et
dénoncer comme tel dans les propres
propos de la stratégie
nationale de développement du frais de
ferroviaire qui écrit textuellement
les trois tests de vue de la Commission
européenne et ce
non pas d'hier mais il y a quelques
années en quelque sorte
où est la possible où a été
la possibilité diplomatie politique
offensive de la France et de la voie de
la France dans
ce dossier qui est un dossier qui peut
certes
paraître
mineure dans l'opinion publique parce
que hier ça fait pas la une des journaux
mais dont vous vous accorderez vous vous
accorderez avec nous avec l'ensemble des
commissaires pour dire que c'est un
enjeu majeur un des enjeux majeurs de
nos l'obtentions
de nos résultats en matière
écologique et de protection du climat
à court 2030 et moyen terme 2050 merci
encore madame la Première ministre de
vos réponses petite précision que
j'apporte
avant de donner la parole à la première
ministre
sauf à ce que j'ai été inattentif
depuis le début de ces auditions
puisqu'on a déjà auditionné plus d'une
quinzaine de personnes
je n'ai entendu aucune je dis bien
aucune personne faire un lien
automatique
ni même aucun lien entre la
transformation des piquants et ça et un
risque accru pour fraté SNCF je dis bien
aucune personne n'a évoqué ce risque à
ce jour sauf dans les questions mais
aucun de nos interlocuteurs je tiens à
le préciser et chacun pourra le vérifier
sur les auditions que nous avons
conduites madame la Première ministre
je voudrais rappeler l'objectif de la
réforme qui a été menée en 2018
d'abord
de désendetter la SNCF qui devait avoir
à l'époque 60 milliards de dettes
de façon à préparer une structure viable
et à même d'affronter la concurrence
décider par les paquets ferroviaires
successifs depuis les années 2000
donc c'était l'objet de cette réforme
qui a été largement débattue au
Parlement vous l'avez rappelé à la fois
d'assurer cette viabilité du groupe SNCF
dans la durée de mettre en place les
règles européennes en transposant les
règles de séparation et évidemment de
créer une entité financièrement pérenne
alors vous me dites on aurait pu
s'interroger sur la viabilité j'ai du
mal à vous suivre parce que je crois
avoir dit dans mon propos introductif
que juste après sa création et pour la
première fois Fret SNCF a enfin
est enfin sorti des déficits permanents
auxquels elle faisait face depuis des
années donc je pense qu'en effet la
structure telle qu'elle a été créée a
montré qu'elle pouvait assurer une
pérennité une viabilité de ses activités
évidemment ça ne change pas le fait que
dans les échanges qu'on avait eu avec la
commission ce qui avait été évidemment
la réforme ferroviaire a fait l'objet
d'échanges avec la commission qui a
validé l'organisation d'ensemble et
c'est apostériori qu'elle a soulevé des
questions d'être d'État notamment suite
au plan de qui avait été déposé mais la
réalité de ce qu'elle questionne au
travers de la procédure qu'elle a
engagée c'est finalement le bilan dont
je rappelle qu'il est de toute façon en
application des règles européennes
tenues depuis le début des années 2000
avec des contes qui manifestement
montrent qu'il y a un endettement de la
SNCF qui était jusqu'à présent dans les
pics et qui n'a évidemment pas été
transféré à une entité qui n'aurait été
pas viable si on avait voulu créer une
société avec la dette telle qu'elle
existait dans les contes de la SNCF de
la SNCF mobilité à l'époque ensuite vous
questionnez sur ce qui s'est passé à
l'automne 2022 et les éventuels
changements d'humeur de la Commission à
ce moment là j'étais ministre en charge
du travail et donc je suis incapable de
vous dire qu'elles étaient les états
d'âmes et les humeurs de la commission
sur le sujet de fret SNCF à ce moment là
et pour
pardon à l'automne 2022
c'est vrai non honnêtement j'ai pas j'ai
pas suivi ces dossiers j'avais
éventuellement d'autres d'autres sujets
sur la table mais moi j'ai pas suivi le
détail des évolutions que vous supposez
psychologique de de la Commission
européenne à cette époque et vous me
dites dans quelle mesure la Commission a
tenu compte de l'intérêt de l'importance
du fret en termes du fret ferroviaire en
termes de transition écologique
je pense que si la solution qui se met
en place dans laquelle seuls les trains
entiers sont
seuls les trains entiers
doivent SNCF ne doit se séparer que des
trains entiers c'est bien parce que
l'argument qui a été porté par mon
ministre a été de dire que le reste de
l'activité
ne pouvait pas être exercée par un autre
opérateur que Fred SNCF et que demander
à la SNCF de se retirer de ces trafics
pouvaient mettre en risque
cette poursuite d'une activité de frais
de ferroviaire
avec un risque évident de
[Musique]
contrepart modal si je peux dire au
bénéfice de la route donc je pense que
c'est l'approche qui a été celle de mon
gouvernement de considérer qu'en effet
les enjeux de transition écologique
étaient importants et qu'il fallait
s'assurer que tout évolution de la
structure de fret SNCF ne conduisez pas
à transférer des trafics sur la route et
on considère que ces arguments
écologiques
enfin voilà sont naturels à être pris en
compte par la commission sans préjugés
de la décision qu'elle prendra après sur
votre votre question s'agissant de
la conjugaison d'action avec d'autres
d'autres
acteurs européens il vous a pas échappé
que les différents acteurs européens
sont en concurrence entre eux donc je ne
suis pas persuadé que les autres pays
souhaitent engager y compris des actions
communes quand
Fred SNCF a fait l'objet de plainte et
fait l'objet d'une procédure lancée par
la commission sur des enjeux de
concurrence voilà enfin ça n'empêche pas
de porter ses enjeux c'est important du
frais de ferroviaire dans la transition
écologique
ce qui nous rend confiance sur la
solution telle qu'elle a été retenue
avec le maintien d'une part importante
de l'activité de fret SNCF et non pas de
transfert ou de retrait de frais SNCF de
ces trafic qu'on ne souhaite pas
évidemment voir sur la route
merci à la première ministre je rappelle
que donc ce qu'on évoque comme devant
rester dans l'une des deux entreprises
qui succéderaient à fêter SNCF
représente aujourd'hui 90% des salariés
80% des trafics et 66 10% du chiffre
d'affaires et que c'est ce sont des
activités autour du wagon isolé mais
aussi des trains entiers avec des moyens
non dédiés et irréguliers on a donc une
question de madame Huguette cenia
ensuite monsieur Mathieu Marchaux madame
la vice-présidente vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre merci pour votre intervention
cohérente j'ai juste deux questions à
vous poser
les intervenants auditionnés jusqu'ici
au sein de la commission d'enquête font
état d'un niveau d'aide publique au
secteur du fret historiquement limité
qui a toutefois été relevé à partir de
la fin des années 2010 le relèvement des
aides accordées au fret faisait-il parti
de votre stratégie pour ces secteurs
estimez-vous que le niveau d'être prévu
dans le plan de discontinuité proposée
par la France soit suffisant pour
assurer le fonctionnement à moyen et
long terme et à long terme du secteur du
du fret je vous remercie
il en est plus sur le secteur
précisément madame la Première ministre
alors effectivement moi j'ai pas les
derniers chiffres en tête j'ai pas
l'occasion de regarder en détail avec le
ministre des Transports le niveau des
aides je pense que c'était effectivement
important de tenir compte des avantages
du frais de ferroviaire en termes de
transition écologique et on a répondu en
tout cas moi j'ai répondu aux demandes
du ministre sur le niveau de soutien qui
était accordé au frais de ferroviaire je
suis pas dans mes fonctions actuelles
capables de vous expliquer quel est le
détail de ce que le ministre a instruit
pour sa part et m'a proposé
monsieur le député Mathieu Mathieu
monsieur le député du Nord vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur madame la Première ministre
vous avez été ministre des Transports
pendant trois ans depuis 2017 la
Commission européenne n'a cessé de
demander à plusieurs reprises au
gouvernement des renseignements le 22
décembre 2017 le 26 février 2018 le 8
mai 2018 le 25 juillet 2018 le 22
février 2019 j'ajoute cannabis à faire
datant de 2019 relatif au projet
d'ordonnance porte en diverses
dispositions relatives et la nouvelle
SNCF je cite un extrait la solution qui
consiste en une absence de transfert de
dette même temporaire peut s'apparenter
un apurement de cette dette historique
par SNCF mobilité et soulève la question
des aides d'État pour cette activité en
concurrence dont il appartiendra à la
Commission européenne d'apprécier la
comptabilité et la compatibilité pardon
avec le droit de l'Union européenne vous
avez donc été semble-t-il est alerté à
plusieurs reprises du risque pour ses
aides d'être mises en cause par la
Commission européenne vous ne craignez
pas à l'époque que ces aides un truc
qualifiés d'illégal et donc il y avait
un risque d'existence à terme pour Fret
SNCF SNCF pardon le 22 mai 2023 en tant
que première ministre vous avez présenté
un plan le plan du gouvernement contre
le réchauffement climatique avec des
jeux objectifs ambitieux fixés en
prévoyant une diminution de moitié des
émissions de CO2 d'ici 2030 et le 23 mai
Clément bonne annonce la liquidation de
fret SNCF curieux en même temps au
détriment des Français Encore une fois
en optant pour la liquidation de fret
SNCF et la discontinuité vous pliez une
nouvelle fois aux demandes de la
Commission européenne vous prenez ainsi
le risque de faire disparaître un
opérateur historique avec des emplois
500 en jeu les trains les plus rentables
vont devoir être abandonnés 20% du
chiffre d'affaires et 30% de l'activité
et la vente de 40% des actifs
immobiliers en 15 ans c'est 10000
emplois qui ont disparu et chez moi à
Somain dans l'une des plus grandes gares
des Hauts de France de triage c'est 95%
des emplois qui ont disparu 1500 à une
cinquantaine aujourd'hui d'emplois et le
risque c'est de mettre un million de
camions sur nos routes demain
pour les discours moralisant qu'on
reçoit assez souvent en matière
d'écologie on y repassera madame la
Première ministre l'ancien ministre des
Transports Djebari qui vous a succédé
aurait lui opté pour le rapport de force
si nous l'a dit ici
je le cite la réalité de l'exercice d'un
ministre quand on est ministre français
ce qui est bien souvent le cas en Europe
il y a des positions divergentes la
Commission européenne applique des
règles convoquer les États et le
Parlement européen ces règles parfois
les états constatent qu'elles s'exercent
au détriment de leurs intérêts oui il
faut un rapport de force on a
l'impression aujourd'hui que quand
Bruxelles demande votre gouvernement
exécute alors madame la Première
ministre vous êtes à la tête du
gouvernement et vous avez un ministre
des Transports Clément bonne est-ce que
vous jugez aujourd'hui que votre
gouvernement est trop faible avec
Bruxelles
j'invite tous les collègues à ne pas
forcément changer du tout au tout le
temps de voie qu'ils adoptait jusqu'ici
dans les auditions simplement parce que
nous avons madame la Première ministre
en face en face de nous même la première
ministre
si tu as regardé l'évolution des trafics
de frais de ferroviaire et à regarder à
quel moment ça a commencé à baisser et
depuis quand ça se redresse
voilà donc je vous invite simplement à
regarder la réalité en face c'est plus
commode pour échanger plutôt que de
partir de postules à faux donc je pense
qu'en effet pas plus que vous je me
satisfait de la part du frais de
ferroviaire dans le transport de
marchandises mais au lieu voilà de s'en
prendre à Bruxelles on essaye d'agir
très concrètement on essaie d'agir en
remettant un état un réseau ferré qui a
été abandonné pendant des décennies
c'est la politique que moi j'ai menée en
tant que ministre des Transports que les
gouvernements qui les ministres qui
m'ont succédé ont continué et c'est la
politique que mène mon gouvernement
d'investir pour remettre en état un
réseau ferré parce que je ne vois pas
bien comment on pourrait redresser le
fait de ferroviaire sans remettre en
état le réseau donc on a mobilisé des
moyens comme personne ne l'avait fait
avant nous pour remettre en état le
réseau on a donné des priorités aux
frais de ferroviaire parce que si les
trains s'arrêtent dès qu'il y a des
travaux ou si systématiquement le frais
de ferroviaire passe après des voyageurs
on n'arrive pas à répondre aux attentes
des entreprises qui recouvrent au frais
de ferroviaire donc je pense que voilà
au-delà des incantations il y a des
actions très concrètes dont je constate
qu'elles ont permis un redressement du
frais de ferroviaire malgré la guerre en
Ukraine malgré auparavant la crise covid
et je pense que cette action il faut en
effet la continuer et je crois
s'agissant de l'option qui a été prise
l'option de discontinuité qui a été
prise par mon gouvernement alors
certains peuvent dire on va aller on va
aller en effet au rapport de force
moi je je redis très clairement mais
j'imagine que le ministre Clément bonne
a eu l'occasion de le dire soit on
pouvait très bien ne rien faire c'est la
procédure se poursuivre avec un risque
clair que la Commission confirme infinie
qu'il y avait une aide d'État illégal et
que Fred SNCF soit amené à la rembourser
dans cette hypothèse c'est simplement
l'arrêt de mort de l'entreprise ou alors
prendre des responsabilités ce qui est
en effet peut-être plus compliqué de
prendre ses responsabilités ce qui veut
dire trouver le chemin pour éviter cette
situation de remboursement c'est la
réponse de la discontinuité c'est celle
que mon ministre a choisi je la soutiens
pleinement parce que je pense que c'est
la seule voie pour assurer la survie de
cette activité majeure qui est le frais
de ferroviaire
merci la première ministre madame
Mathilde Jonquières madame la
vice-présidente vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre j'ai deux questions
que je vais vous poser de manière très
rapide enfin très simple par rapport aux
objectifs annoncés en 2018 qu'est-ce qui
justifie aujourd'hui la restructuration
de la filière et deuxième question si
j'ai bien noté tout à l'heure vous avez
évoqué des mesures pour que le fret ne
soit plus la part d'ajustement variable
j'aurais voulu savoir si vous auriez pu
détailler en fait ces mesures pour
éviter effectivement que le fret reste
la part d'ajustement variable merci
alors enfin je sais pas si on doit
rentrer dans le détail de la gestion des
sillons mais j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire si systématiquement pas le frais de
soyez roulent dans la journée
auquel cas il peut être en concurrence
dans l'utilisation des sillons avec des
trains de voyageurs il est d'autant plus
que je pense que toutes les régions et
on peut que les soutenir souhaitent
renforcer la fréquence des desserts
autour des agglomérations donc soit le
fret essaye de circuler dans la journée
et il se heurte à des trains de
voyageurs soit il essaye de circuler la
nuit et comme par ailleurs on est en
train de moderniser le réseau on peut en
effet avoir des travaux sur les voies
ferrées l'objectif de la politique et
notamment des priorités que moi j'ai
porté dans le la stratégie nationale du
fret ferroviaire et qui est reprise
depuis c'est de dire qu'on ne peut pas
considérer qu'on répond aux besoins de
toutes les activités qu'on dégage les
plages nécessaires pour faire les
travaux et que le Fred se débrouille
pour survivre dans cet univers là et
effectivement il doit y avoir la
capacité à garantir aux
usagers du frais de ferroviaire aux
entreprises qui recouvrent auprès de
ferroviaire
une visibilité une régularité du frais
de ferroviaire ce qui veut dire
forcément donner une certaine priorité
au frais de ferroviaire pour permettre à
cette activité de t'exprimer pleinement
sa pertinence
[Musique]
merci la parole est à Monsieur Thomas
porte député de cette Saint-Denis est
très impliquée dans nos travaux vous
allez la parole monsieur le député
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre
avant d'être ministre des Transports
vous avez aussi été directrice de la
stratégie de Guillaume Pepy à la SNCF le
même Guillaume Pepy qui a reconnu hier
Louis Gallois
vous avez été directrice de la stratégie
sur une période où le fret a été le
parent pauvre ou le fret a subi des
multiples plans de restructuration ou le
fret a subi des suppressions d'emplois
ou le fret a été mis de côté moi
j'aimerais avoir votre point de vue
première question est-ce que vous
considérez qu'en tant que directrice
stratégique de l'époque votre action a
été utile pour développer le frais de
ferroviaire public deuxième question
on évoque la procédure de discontinuité
d'autres pays européens sont concernés
la Grèce la Bulgarie la Roumanie
l'Italie l'Allemagne la France est la
seule qui a choisi aujourd'hui la
procédure de discontinuité la France est
la seule qui a choisi des quasiment
l'ouverture de l'enquête de la
Commission européenne de présenter une
stratégie qui est une stratégie de
liquidation de fret SNCF
car cette procédure discontinuité elle
prévoit par exemple que les flux les
plus rentables soit transférées à des
opérateurs privés sans que la nouvelle
entité ne puisse se porter candidate
pendant les 10 prochaines années sur ces
trains là donc vous nous expliquez que
vous voulez faire passer la part modale
de transport de marchandises de 9% à 18
% avec un opérateur public qui va être
affaibli qui va être amputé d'une partie
de ton personnel une partie de son
infrastructure qui ne pourra plus
candidater sur un transport qui est
rentable donc on a du mal à voir quelle
est la stratégie véritable derrière
cette procédure de continuité et est-ce
qu'il n'y a pas simplement la volonté de
la Commission européenne de liquider
l'opérateur public ferroviaire en France
et dernière question vous avez aussi été
à l'époque à la manière pour mettre en
place ce qu'on appelle la SNCF la
séparation par activité qui cloisonnent
des activités qui est quelque chose qui
est dénoncé depuis des années par les
organisations syndicales et par les
cheminots qui ne permet pas de
rationaliser de manière intelligente
l'activité est-ce que vous considérez
aujourd'hui que la séparation par
activité que vous avez porté n'est pas
non plus un frein au développement du
service public ferroviaire fret dans
notre pays
c'est pas très bien en tant que quoi
j'ai porté la stratégie de séparation
par activité je pense qu'il y a des
règles européennes qui prévoit notamment
la séparation du gestionnaire
d'infrastructures ça doit remonter
maintenant plusieurs décennies qui
prévoit effectivement que les activités
au fur et à mesure qu'elles sont mises
en concurrence et ça paraît assez
logique doivent avoir une comptabilité
une organisation distincte donc je vois
pas très bien titre de quoi vous
considérez que c'est moi qui ai porté la
réorganisation de la SNCF suite vous
m'interrogez sur mon rôle de directrice
de la stratégie de la SNCF donc je vous
confirme que c'était sous la présidence
de Monsieur Louis Gallois puis madame
Anne-Marie Idrac j'imagine que vous avez
peut-être eu l'occasion de de les
auditionner donc dès cette époque il y
avait des difficultés dans l'activité de
fret qui a supposé qu'il y ait un plan
de restructuration qui avait été à
l'époque présenté par le directeur du
fret que vous avez peut-être eu
l'occasion
passionné qui a conduit à ce moment là à
une
recapitalisation de fret SNCF pour
assurer sa pérennité pas plus que vous
je ne peux me réjouir que l'activité
n'est pas été rendue viable à cette
époque et que la part du fret
ferroviaire est continué à baisser
jusque grosso modo au début de ce
quinquennat en tout cas je peux me
réjouir en ayant été ministre des
Transports ministres de l'écologie et
première ministre aujourd'hui de voir
qu'on a pu enrayer cette baisse de
l'activité du frais de ferroviaire et
cette érosion de la part modale du frais
de ferroviaire ensuite vous faites une
description qui est la vôtre sur les
conséquences de la discontinuité cette
discontinuité elle conduit à ce que 20%
du chiffre d'affaires doivent être cédés
évidemment c'est important évidemment je
mesure à quel point pardon
20% doivent être cédés donc c'est vrai
que c'est important et on va pas voilà
épiloguer savoir si ces 20 enfin je
pense qu'il y a des chiffres et
pourra échanger les équipes auront
échanger en dehors de cette de cette
audition vous le savez comme moi quand
on a une procédure qui va au bout
sans qu'on trouve une solution du type
discontinuité le risque c'est d'aller
jusqu'à 50 %, est-ce que c'est ça que
vous souhaitez je vous renvoie la
jurisprudence d'aditalia c'est ce qui
est arrivé à cette compagnie aérienne et
c'est ce qu'on a voulu éviter
je pense que la discussion sont les
pourcentages entre 20 et 30 les liés au
trafic et au chiffre d'affaires mais les
chiffres sont relativement proches je
voulais juste réagir à la question sur
la gestion par activité on a reçu Louis
Gallois hier je lui ai posé cette
question et personne n'a rebondi
d'ailleurs à ce moment-là
je passe la parole à Madame Christine
Arrighi même la rapporteur spécial
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre alors je vais
commencer mon propos par une anecdote
une anecdote courte mais qui nous
conduit naturellement au fret lorsque
j'ai fait campagne pour les actions
législatives j'étais alors candidate
écologiste nupes j'ai fait un discours
sur les transports parce que je
considère que c'est la mère de toutes
les batailles et j'étais très applaudie
et à la fin de mon discours j'ai indiqué
que en fait ils avaient applaudis
Elisabeth borne ministre des Transports
c'est le public était un public de
militants et ils ont été évidemment très
étonnés que entre temps c'est à dire
entre 2018 puisque c'était à cette
époque là vos propos en tant que
ministre des Transports et 2022 au
moment de ma campagne ne se soit passé
pas passé grand chose au niveau des
transports et au niveau notamment de la
SNCF sans parler de la question qui
était évoquée aujourd'hui sur le
démantèlement au niveau de fret SNCF
alors au-delà de l'anecdote je
aujourd'hui dans le propos que vous avez
tenu le 12 juillet 2023 aujourd'hui
l'accélération continue on peut douter
de cette accélération en tout cas de ce
qu'on en constate aujourd'hui et nous
sommes bel et bien sur le chemin de la
neutralité carbone alors je vais vous
poser ma question en fait deux questions
pensez-vous aujourd'hui après les
rapports éclairants et éclairés du
Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures et ceux de la RT que le
développement et le financement du fret
soit compatible avec la construction de
nouvelles autoroutes qui plus est
concédés intégrant des routes déjà
financées par l'impôt comme la 69 entre
Toulouse et Castres j'aimerais bien
avoir votre point de vue à la fois sur
ce dossier là et sa compatibilité avec
la possibilité de donner de l'argent et
de tout faire tourner les mobilités vers
le fret plutôt que vers le routier ça me
première question mais il n'y a pas que
la 69 qui soit concerné mais en tout
état de cause il y a un vrai rapport
entre le fait de construire des
autoroutes le fait de mettre sur la
route des camions en lieu et place d'un
fret et de la du financement de ce fret
par l'argent que l'on met sur la route
et ma deuxième question nous assistons à
ce jour à des annonces d'une valse de
milliards voire ou de millions selon de
quand quelqu'un on se situe en matière
de ferroviaire vous avez vous-même
annoncé un plan de 100 milliards d'euros
à quand une grande loi de programmation
du ferroviaire qui nous détaille de
façon très précise ce qui relève des
régions CPER pour l'instant les contrats
ne sont pas encore signés ou à tout le
mois à ma connaissance 2 et ceux qui
relève de la responsabilité de l'État
que ce soit pour les relations avec les
métropoles et leur métropolitain mais
que ce soit également pour la question
du fret qui naturellement comme vous
venez de le dire si on ne régénère pas
le réseau on ne pourra pas faire rouler
de nuit le les transports de
marchandises qui je le rappelle et vous
connaissez les chiffres le fret ça
consomme 6 fois moins d'énergie que la
route
et 9 mois moins de gaz à effet de serre
et ça allait vite évidemment les
externalités négatives congestions
accident que l'on peut avoir sur
l'autoroute ou sur la route je vous
remercie madame la Première ministre
juste là aussi avant de vous donner la
parole à Madame le Premier ministre je
rappelle qu'on a auditionné les deux
anciens PDG de SNCF réseau depuis le
début et aussi bien Patrick jeantais que
Luc Lallemand ont reconnu que ils
avaient eu des moyens supplémentaires au
cours de leur exercice pour rénover le
réseau ferroviaire ils l'ont ils ont
assisté à l'époque personne n'est
intervenu pour les contredire et que le
montant sur dédié au frais de
ferroviaire a été donné dans les CPR à
plusieurs reprises 930 millions d'euros
ça a été ça a été dit madame la Première
ministre
j'entends bien mais c'est ma question à
madame la Première ministre merci
alors donc je vous confirme que on
s'organise pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone et vous voyez ce matin j'ai pu
échanger avec tous les membres du
Conseil national de la refondation sur
la façon dont on va déployer notre
planification écologique qui suppose
d'agir dans tous les domaines
l'industrie le bâtiment des déplacements
d'alimentation pour atteindre cette
neutralité carbone et je pense que ici
on peut tous se réjouir d'avoir doublé
le rythme des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre dans le précédent quinquennat
par rapport au quinquennat précédent et
on se fixe l'objectif et nous sommes
apparemment sur la bonne trajectoire de
doubler à nouveau le rythme enfin le
rythme de baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ça suppose d'agir dans
tous les domaines et j'ai pas de doute
que la présidente de votre groupe que
j'ai eu l'occasion de voir il y a
quelques jours pourra vous passer le
document que nous avons
vous présenter sur cette planification
écologique qui concerne comme je le
disais tous les secteurs en effet ça
suppose d'investir davantage sur le
ferroviaire à la fois en termes de
régénération et donc on a bien
conscience qu'il va falloir continuer à
augmenter les montants qui sont
consacrés à la régénération ça suppose
aussi d'investir davantage pour
développer les capacités du réseau je
vous renvoie au mandats qui ont été
donnés au préfet qui sont en train de
négocier des contrats de plans vous
pourrez constater qu'on a fortement
réduit la part des crédits qui sont
consacrés à la route pour augmenter
significativement la part des crédits
qui sont consacrés au ferroviaires donc
on joue confirme qu'on mène une
stratégie cohérente qui vise
à favoriser les modes alternatifs à la
route qui vise par ailleurs à favoriser
les déplacements enfin sortir de
l'utilisation
individuelle de la voiture thermique ce
qui veut dire aussi développer par
exemple du covoiturage et accompagner
nos concitoyens pour passer sur des
mobilités décarbonées donc c'est
l'ensemble de ces actions qui doit nous
permettre de d'atteindre les -55% d'ici
2030 et d'atteindre la neutralité
carbone et je vous confirme je pense
qu'on est sur la bonne voie
je donne la parole à Monsieur Nicolas
Rey monsieur le vice-président vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre en octobre 2014 le
gouvernement de l'époque décidait
l'abandon de l'écotaxe sur les poids
lourds voté en 2009 dans la Loi Grenelle
en octobre de 14 on était pas ministres
mais vous étiez la directrice de cabinet
de la ministre de l'écologie Madame
Royale cet abandon avec conduit l'État à
verser près d'un milliard d'indemnités à
la société eco-move avec le recul
ne pensez-vous pas que cette outil était
un bon moyen de résoudre la distorsion
entre la route et le rail dans la mesure
où les camions étrangers vous le savez
traverse notre réseau routier sans péage
contrairement au train qui paye des
redevances n'étaient pas un bon moyen de
aussi pour favoriser le rapport modal
que l'on souhaite intensifier et enfin
deuxième question où en est-on de l'idée
de création d'une vignette payée par les
poids lourds étrangers évoqués plusieurs
fois récemment par votre ministre
monsieur Béchu par rapport à ce projet
alors je vous confirme que
je pense que
il n'est pas normal qu'on puisse avoir
des poids lourds qui traversent notre
pays sont contribués du tout au
financement nos infrastructures et on
sait très bien que les camions depuis
plusieurs années ont des réservoirs qui
leur permettent de faire le plein au
Luxembourg de traverser le pays et de
refaire le plein en Espagne sans avoir
du tout contribué à payer le moindre
euro pour assurer l'entretien le
développement de notre réseau et dans
l'occurrence de notre réseau routier une
démarche avait été lancée pour mettre en
place une écotaxe
je pense que ça avait suscité
suffisamment de réticences à l'époque et
de réactions pour que la ministre à
l'époque et moi je n'étais pas ministre
et décidé de mettre un terme au contrat
qui avait été passé qui faille continuer
à réfléchir et qu'il faille continuer à
étudier les solutions qui peuvent
permettre qu'on sorte de cette inégalité
en fait de traitement avec des
transporteurs français qui financent au
travers notamment de la TICPE qui paye
des impôts en tout cas qui participent à
l'entretien de nos infrastructures et
des transporteurs qui peuvent traverser
le pays sans le financer je pense que le
sujet reste d'actualité ensuite comment
peut-on avancer sur ce sujet pour ne pas
inquiéter nos transporteurs et je pense
que aujourd'hui quand on voit
effectivement
l'évolution des prix du gasoil c'est
sans doute pas un contexte tout à fait
propice à des réflexions de ce type là
mais qu'il faille effectivement
continuer à rechercher la bonne façon de
faire contribuer les poids lourds qui
traversent le pays sans participer au
financement des infrastructures ça me
paraît effectivement une réflexion
d'actualité
merci même la première ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Nicolas sangsue
député du Cher merci monsieur le
président madame la Première ministre
vous l'avez souligné le fret c'est un
petit peu redressé ces deux dernières
années à la fois en nombre de tonnes
kilomètres transportées et à la fois en
nombre de
en résultat financier pour pour la
filiale fret SAS et donc c'est c'est un
coup de massue qui tombe à la fois sur
les salariés et je dirais sur le pays
que de voir qu'on va être obligé à un
plan de discontinuité qui pourrait
mettre à mal le transport ferroviaire de
fret au moins dans l'immédiat et pour
les quelques années qui viennent ça nous
a été dit d'ailleurs par certains de vos
prédécesseurs alors ma question est
toute simple d'ailleurs si le groupe GDR
a demandé cette commission d'enquête
avec comme rapporteur l'excellent Hubert
vulfrance et parce que nous nous ne
comprenons pas nous ne comprenons pas
aujourd'hui pourquoi c'est à ce moment
là que que cette procédure arrive et
nous ne comprenons pas alors qu'il y a
tant à faire sur la décarbonation des
transports que l'on accepte cette
manière de faire de la part de la
Commission européenne
donc quelques questions d'abord n'y
a-t-il pas un risque majeur à lancer ce
plan négocié avec la commissaire
westigeur qui a priori pour lequel il
existe a priori aucun écrit c'est à dire
qu'on va lancer le plan puisque on lance
la discontinuité avant même que la
Commission européenne accepte ce plan ou
alors il y a des écrits que nous n'avons
pas ensuite avez-vous participé aux
discussions puisque on sait que depuis
l'automne selon les dires de Monsieur
farandoux ça se tendait avec la
commission avez-vous participé à des
discussions sur cette solution
discontinuité et eu égard au peu
d'enthousiasme d'ailleurs
sur ce plan sanction enthousiasme du
président farandon comme comme d'autres
personnes qu'on avait additionné
pourriez-vous nous faire part et nous
transmettre les différents courriers que
vous auriez pu échanger avec la
présidente de la commission
j'ajoute qu'en mai juin 2022 alors que
le semestre de la présidente française
se termine comment en tant que première
ministre vous avez abordé ce sujet au
moment des conclusions de la présidente
française
ensuite y a-t-il aujourd'hui à votre
sens une option différente au plan de
discontinuité envoyée par le ministre au
président de la SNCF sachant que sur les
23 flux concernés dont certains sont les
plus rentables certains pourraient se
reporter sur la route ce qui contrevient
au Green Deal qui est pourtant annoncé
et que deviendrait ses flux dans ce cas
dans ce cas là serait-il possible de
demander à la Commission européenne en
cas de
les personnes où il y a carence de
transport par le fer de les conserver au
sein de Fret SNCF et enfin une question
toute simple si nous allions au bout de
la procédure le président Gallois nous a
précisé que le remboursement
viendrait de fret SNCF vers le groupe
SNCF comment la France ce grand pays
fondateur de l'Union européenne ne
pourrait ne pas assumer cela devant la
Commission européenne
alors vous aurez compris que au travers
de ce plan de discontinuité
notre objectif c'est d'assurer la
viabilité la pérennité du fret
ferroviaire public
avec un risque si on ne le fait pas
d'arriver à une liquidation de la
société frais SNCF bien évidemment et je
j'ai évoqué le fait que
par rapport à d'autres dossiers de
contentieux qui ont pu exister j'ai cité
à l'Italia si on a pu enfin si on est
confiance sur le scénario qui est
présenté avec finalement un maintien
d'une part significatif très
significative de l'activité
c'est notamment compte tenu des échanges
qui ont pu intervenir avec la commission
sur l'importance de préserver le frais
de ferroviaire et d'éviter d'avoir un
report modal sur la route donc je pense
que le fin d'esprit de du plan qui est
mené c'est de se prémunir absolument du
risque d'une liquidation de fret SNCF de
se prémunir d'un transfert modal ou
bénéfice de la route
de protéger au maximum l'activité de
l'opérateur public et de s'assurer du
maintien d'un maximum de trafic sur sur
le ferroviaire
s'agissant des échanges avec la
commission il y a pas eu d'échanges à
mon niveau avec la présidente de la
commission a fortiori deux courriers je
pense que le ministre Clément baume a
évoqué les échanges qu'il a eu à son
niveau avec la Commission et je pense
qu'il a y compris évoqué la possibilité
de transmettre à votre commission les
éventuels échanges qu'il aurait pu avoir
la parole est à Monsieur Pascal Lecan un
député de la Vienne chers collègues vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président merci de venir à cette
audition moi je partirai peut-être de
l'étape d'après on a entendu votre
Ministre la semaine dernière mercredi
monsieur Clément bonne hier monsieur
farouze madame monsieur Bussereau on a
du général aussi on va supposer que
on résout le problème avec l'Union
européenne et que on la discontinuité
est acceptée elle est en place moi
j'aimerais savoir à partir de cette
situation là quels sont les grands axes
de de votre réforme ferroviaire en
général et en particulier sur le fret
et avec peut-être
plus particulièrement la stratégie
nationale du fret et ce que vous avez
évoqué monsieur busseron n'a pas les ce
matin de de cette aberration de voir
tous ces camions passés donc comment on
intégrer l'intermodal quelle
substitution à l'écotaxe qui a été
abandonné au moment de l'arrivée à
Montréal alors que tout était prêt
comment vous envisagez que quand cette
société est créée que la discontinue est
acceptée par l'Union européenne on passe
à l'étape suivante pour réintégrer le
frais de ferroviaire dans une stratégie
nationale du fret en France je vous
remercie
je l'ai évoqué moi je pense que
[Musique]
évidemment on doit favoriser au maximum
le transport de marchandises
pardon ferroviaire ou fluvial le premier
point pour que ce transport qu'on puisse
avoir une augmentation de la part du
ferroviaire c'est déjà d'avoir un réseau
en bon état d'avoir des infrastructures
plus généralement en bon état et donc
c'est tous ceux à quoi on s'emploie
notamment sur la remise en état du
réseau sur l'augmentation des moyens qui
sont consacrés à la régénération de ce
réseau avec un objectif évidemment de
sortir de ce que j'ai pu évoquer au
départ sur l'âge moyen du réseau y
compris quand on se compare à d'autres à
d'autres pays européens c'est aussi le
soutien sur les activités qui sont en
concurrence directe avec la route pour
tenir compte de l'avantage écologique du
transport ferroviaire et donc c'est le
soutien qui se met également en place
ensuite je suis aussi convaincu que la
réindustrialisation c'est aussi une
nouvelle opportunité pour le
développement du frais de ferroviaire
quand pendant des années on a fermé des
usines évidemment c'est aussi des
facteurs de trafic qui ont disparu de
notre territoire et effectivement quand
on est en train de réindustrialiser
notre pays avec 100 000 créations
d'emplois industriels depuis 2017 c'est
aussi une transformation de notre
activité économique qui sera
certainement bénéfique au transport
ferroviaire ensuite sur les
camions en transit et la nécessité de
pouvoir les faire participer je vais
laisser ministre faire des propositions
sur le sujet en tout cas je pense que
c'est un réel problème
est effectivement on doit continuer à
réfléchir à la façon dont on peut faire
participer les poids lourds en transit
sur notre territoire à l'entretien de
nos infrastructures doit s'assurer qu'il
y a la meilleure équité entre les
différents modes de transport mais en
tout cas que ces poids lourds en transit
puissent participer au financement de
nos infrastructures
merci à la première ministre monsieur
Sylvain carrière monsieur le député de
l'Hérault chers collègues vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur madame la
Première ministre le frais de
ferroviaire nécessite des
investissements à hauteur de 20
milliards sur 10 ans pour retrouver sa
fiabilité c'est le bilan que Monsieur
Ferrando dresse deux ans après votre
départ du ministère des Transports neuf
au moins émetteurs de CO2 que le
transport routier c'est pourtant à ce
dernier que toutes les faveurs vont
peut-être car les transporteurs routiers
utilisent des autoroutes gérées par des
sociétés autoritières c'est même société
autoroutières qui ont vu des milliards
d'argent public leur être accordés suite
à votre négociation du prolongement de
leurs concession en 2015 anticorps
soupçonne d'ailleurs du favoritisme dans
ce dossier car oui les multinationales
en charge de la gestion des autoroutes
ont récolté 55 milliards de dividendes
en 30 ans qui n'ont bien évidemment pas
bénéficier au reste du secteur des
transports ce transport routier dans les
coûts sociaux sont très sous-estimés
selon le rapport Spinetta que vous avez
pour un suivi pour toutes les mesures
libérales qu'il contenaient mais
étonnamment pas sur la sous-évaluation
des coûts sociaux du secteur routier
comme la pollution ou la congestion mais
c'est de la faute des grévistes si le
fret est en faillite et en déclin selon
vos termes de 2018 dans le cadre de
cette commission d'enquête j'ai donc
trois questions à vous poser
premièrement pouvez-vous nous dire sur
quelle base avez-vous estimé que la fin
du statut des cheminots au relancerait
le fret ferroviaire d'une meilleure
manière qu'une renationalisation des
autoroutes deuxièmement pourquoi
avez-vous favorisé le secteur routier
alors que ces coûts sociaux sont
massivement sous-estimés et qu'en fait
une connaissance de vos dossiers vous le
savez et enfin Madame la première
ministre pourquoi défendez-vous des
multinationales au lieu de défendre la
souveraineté française et la transition
écologique sur le plan économique nous
serons perdants en étant incapable de se
plier aux accords européens du fit for
fifty-five et donc à prévoir de payer
des pénalités de retard je vous remercie
juste une petite un clin d'oeil à notre
collègue
amusé dans le rapport spinnetta il y
avait justement comme proposition je
crois que c'était à la page 75 la
reprise de la dette de fret SNCF par les
pics de tête à l'époque finalement on
peut considérer que ça a été c'est une
recommandation qui a été suivie madame
la Première ministre oui écoutez je
crois que c'est pas vraiment des
questions je pense que c'est des
attaques je sais pas très bien ce que
vous voulez que je réponde à la
nationalisation des autoroutes ça doit
être 50 milliards d'euros faudrait que
vous nous expliquer où on trouve
l'argent ensuite je enfin voilà enfin
franchement j'ai pas grand chose à
répondre à des questions qui n'en sont
pas
monsieur le rapporteur souhaitait
reprendre la parole ensuite on a une
question de Madame blanc et de nouveau
de Monsieur censure
merci monsieur le président
je vais vous donner un état sans doute
tout à fait subjectif de
j'avais fait auprès de Monsieur Thomas
porte le monsieur
de Monsieur Beaune pardon de monsieur le
ministre lui donner un état de
excusez-moi
c'est bien compliqué
un état de mes convictions
2000 2007 2015
un régime
séquence de régime d'aide
visé par la Commission européenne
et lorsque progressivement nous
interrogeons les mini en charge les
transports
il y a
une non-réponse
ou les réponses particulièrement
dilatoires
sur les échanges de contrôle d'audit
entre la France et la Commission
européenne
au titre de l'accord de 2005
qui
entamait et actait la restructuration
jusqu'à 2008
là je vous avouerait que une grande
interrogation de responsabilité
de l'autre partie quand on respecte
d'un accord qui
entre 2008 et 2015 en porte déjà
j'imagine quelques milliards qui sont
demandés par la Commission européenne
2015 il y a cette plante de la rafle que
j'estime un peu quand même tardif
tardive installer comme motorité de
contrôle en 2010 5 ans plus tard
sonnette d'alarme bref
je suis conduit à penser madame la
Première ministre que
par négligence
au mieux
par
duplicité au pire
et bien nous en arrivons
en 2019
après voilà quelques plans qui hésitent
commence à agiter la question nous en
arrivons en 2019 à cette fameuse
transformation épique et ça
alors
que j'ai qualifié tout à l'heure de
portant sur les fonds bâtissements une
société au sens libéral du terme non
viable
formidable
formidable que des libéraux portent une
société une sa non viable dès le départ
en fait aujourd'hui
vous dites
nous avons
garanti la viabilité
et les résultats témoignent ah oui mais
les résultats témoignent que la
discontinuité c'est si vie civile à sa
frette SNCF aujourd'hui
pour une autre entité mais si j'y
aujourd'hui
la SA frette SNCF donc
je suis convaincu que cette
transformation de sa en épique
en et ça réunissaient les conditions de
cette enterrement de première classe
auquel nous assistons aujourd'hui
je vous livre ma conviction je suis
enfin
interrogatif nous sommes dans
une annonce de plantes discontinuité
question était posée sur
quel crédit accordé à la parole
la parole de Madame
la Commissaire européenne par ailleurs
aujourd'hui
quelque peu extraite
seul ministre nous a répondu sur ce
point il nous a dit mais
n'attendez pas n'attendez pas une lettre
signée de la Commission européenne pour
nous dire c'est bon les sanctions sont
levées qu'est-ce qui nous dit monsieur
le ministre il nous dit c'est à
nous-mêmes à l'exécutif français au
gouvernement bien de mettre en œuvre
ce plan de discontinuité alors moi je
vous pose une simple question madame la
ministre dès lors que
la première ministre dès lors que votre
Ministre
a écrit
une lettre de commande au président
farandou posant explicitement et
engageant le plan de discontinuité
comment se fait-il que quatre mois plus
tard
nous n'ayons pas de réponse
quelle qu'elle soit d'appréciation de la
Commission européenne car ce plan il est
engagé objectivement
est-ce que sur les trois à quatre lignes
rouges que votre ministre nous a dit
à quel autre ministre nous a dit veiller
c'est-à-dire les enjeux sociaux les
enjeux de viabilité sur l'avenir de
cette entité dans la filière recomposée
du fret et sur le report modal est-ce
que vous négociez encore quelque chose
qui serait pas encore au carré sur les
lignes rouges en particulier que vous
avez que votre ministre a évoqué
une conviction et une question madame la
ministre des convictions et une question
première ministre pardon
en fait je enfin j'entends votre
conviction je ne sais pas comment enfin
voilà c'est c'est votre choix je peux
pas laisser dire qu'on a créé une
société anonyme non viable on a créé une
société anonyme avec un bilan qui était
qui lui permettait d'avoir une viabilité
et je note et je l'ai dit que pour la
première fois depuis des décennies cette
entreprise
a dégager des résultats donc je pense
que c'est le signe qu'en effet la
structure elle est économiquement viable
qu'il y ait par ailleurs une plainte sur
des aides d'État liés
en effet à ce que vous avez évoqué
depuis 2007 et au déficit accumulé au
sein des SNCF mobilité par le fret SNCF
c'est autre chose mais structure elle
est viable et son bilan a été conçu pour
qu'elle le soit ensuite vous vous
étonnez de pas avoir de retour de la
commission c'est simplement la procédure
quand une commission quand la commission
ouvre une enquête elle mène son enquête
et le
la réponse sur l'issue de cette enquête
ça n'est jamais en 4 mois c'est une
procédure qui va prendre 18 mois le
ministre qui a échangé en amont avec la
commission
à évoquer les lignes rouges et les
points importants alors les points
importants pour nous sur l'absence
d'impact au plan social sur le fait
d'éviter d'avoir des transferts un
transfert modal au profit de la route
sur le fait de s'assurer qu'on avait une
entreprise qui était viable c'est sur
cette base là que le schéma a été conçu
et qu'il faut le mettre en oeuvre pour
que au moment de clôturer son enquête la
Commission constate qu'il y a eu en
effet la discontinuité mais voilà c'est
c'est il n'y aura pas d'échanges dans le
cadre de ces procédures ouvertes par la
Commission dans ce cas particulier comme
dans tous les autres il n'y a plus
d'échanges entre le les autorités du
pays et la Commission européenne qui
déroule son enquête en toute
indépendance et c'est voilà ce qui
garantit aussi la sécurité juridique de
la décision qui sera prise le moment
venu par la Commission
puisqu'il ne me reste plus que quelques
minutes je vais donner la parole
successivement aux trois collègues on
leur demandant d'être assez court si
possible madame Sophie blanc madame la
députée des Pyrénées-Orientales vous
avez la parole je vous remercie monsieur
le Président je serai très belle j'ai
deux petites questions sur la porteur
madame la Première ministre
le terminal ferroviaire urbain chapelle
international à Paris a été inauguré par
vous en présence de Madame Hidalgo en
juin 2018 et elle devait permettre au
train de marchandises d'approvisionner
Paris pour éviter le passage de 43000
poids lourds chaque année coût total de
cette opération 80 millions d'euros et
aujourd'hui on constate qu'aucun train
n'est arrivé donc ne s'agit-il pas là
d'un gaspillage public pourquoi avoir
cette gare si aucun train ne l'utilise
et est-ce que ce projet était chiffré à
l'époque et deuxième question
un million milliards d'euros a été
consacré en 2021 tout cofinancement
confondus on va dire spécifiquement sur
pour le fret et dans le plan de relance
du gouvernement pour le fret en octobre
2021 il y a le développement des
autoroutes ferroviaires dont l'axe
Perpignan Rungis c'est un train qui
exploitait vous vous le savez Paret SNCF
de manière saisonnière et qui circule 5
jours par semaine avec une capacité de
12 wagons et il a été suspendu pendant
deux ans le 25 mai dernier le ministre
Clément bonne explique que la SNCF ne
sera plus l'opérateur de ce train alors
n'y a-t-il pas un risque que cette ligne
ferme définitivement et qu'elle sort
sera réservée aux salariés qui sont
basés à Perpignan et opérant sur ce que
l'on appelle le train des primeurs je
vous remercie on comprend tout de suite
la question de Monsieur Nicolas censu
monsieur le député du Cher
pardon merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre d'abord
juste une précision c'est quand même
ubuesque que la Commission européenne
lance une procédure sur une SAS qui en
fait aurait touché 170 millions d'euros
alors que la procédure devait concerne
un épique qui n'existe plus parce que
c'est ça la réalité en fait ça concerne
un épique les 5 milliards 139 euros qui
n'existe plus donc il y a quand même
quelque chose d'ubuesque mais ça c'est
une juste une précision vous avez été
ministre des Transports et de l'écologie
pendant trois ans 2017-2020 donc vous
aviez en charge ce dossier
pourriez-vous nous transmettre tous les
échanges et courrier sur ce dossier du
fret avec la Commission européenne et
les notes évidemment dans ce cadre là
deuxième question j'ai bien compris que
depuis 2022 vous n'aviez pas eu
d'échanger pistolaire avec la présidente
de la Commission européenne sur ce sujet
en tant que tel
mais je ne doute pas qu'il y a eu quand
même délier des liens entre votre
cabinet et sans doute les cabinets de la
Commission de la président de la
Commission européenne comme il y a eu
des liens entre votre cabinet vous-même
et le ministère des Transports
pourriez-vous évidemment dans le même
cadre nous faire parvenir tous les
courriers et des notes afférents à ce
dossier
et enfin Monsieur Thomas porte monsieur
le député de Seine-Saint-Denis chers
collègues merci monsieur le Président je
rebondis d'abord sur pour prolonger la
question de mon collègue Nicolas sangsue
pour un dossier qui est pris soit disant
en charge au plus haut niveau de l'État
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas d'échange
entre la première ministre et la
Commission européenne nous surprend donc
on souhaite avoir toute trace d'échange
qu'il y a pu avoir entre votre cabinet
entre les différents intervenants pour
qu'on puisse regarder ce qui s'est dit
et voir comment l'État négocie et ou en
sommes-nous de cette procédure parce
qu'il est quand même surprenant que la
première ministre de ce pays n'est pas
d'échange direct avec la Commission
européenne sur un sujet aussi majeur que
le fret dans un moment aussi important
pour la transition écologique j'ai deux
autres questions dans le plan de
discontinuité présenté par Clément bonne
il est prévu que les cheminots qui
assurent la maintenance passent dans une
filiale de droit privé ce qui n'est pas
une demande de la Commission européenne
donc pourquoi mettre cette proposition
dans le plan de de continuité alors que
la Commission européenne ne demande pas
cela et dernière question on parle
beaucoup du report modal inversé sauf
qu'on sait aujourd'hui que certains des
23 flux qui sont demandés qui est
demandé qui vont être cédés et qui
appartient aujourd'hui à la SNCF sont
déjà arrêtés la SNCF anticipée la
session de ces 23 trafic donc il y a
déjà des marchandises qui ne sont plus
sur le rail et qui sont sur la route il
n'y a aucune garantie à ce que demain
c'est 23 flux soit sur du transport
ferroviaire que quand de faire le
gouvernement si demain c'est 23 flux ne
repasse pas via des entreprises privées
à minima sur le rail est-ce que le
gouvernement va laisser ces 23 flux s'il
n'y a pas de repreneur passer sur la
route en regardant passer les camions
juste peut-être Nicolas Rey qui s'est
merci de votre patience madame la
première mission une dernière question
notre collègue rapide très rapide
suite à la procédure engagée par la
Commission européenne à l'encontre de
fraté SNCF nous sommes en train de
chercher une solution et j'ai
l'impression que il y a une intimité
pour dire qu'on qu'on la met en oeuvre
un peu à contrecoeur parce que elle est
l'application du dogme du libre
concurrence absolue dans un secteur qui
ne s'y prête pas forcément est-ce que ce
n'est pas le signe d'une perte
d'influence de la France aussi au niveau
européen pour adapter ses règles de la
concurrence sur un secteur aussi
important que les transports
madame la Première ministre pour une
dernière réponse
alors sur chapelle internationale on
peut pas tout à la fois nous reprocher
de ne pas en faire suffisamment pour le
frais de ferroviaire et nous reprocher
d'avoir un investissement pour permettre
à des trains d'arriver directement dans
Paris à la place de camion je suis pas
ministre des Transports je ne suis pas
capable de vous dire ce qui se passe sur
le réseau de la Gare du Nord qui empêche
qui est du trafic donc je ne suis pas en
situation de vous répondre mais je
demanderai à mon ministre de vous
répondre sur le sujet de la même façon
je ne suis pas en charge de l'appel à
manifestation d'intérêt sur Perpignan
Rungis je peux vous dire
qu'effectivement je suis bien conscient
de l'importance de ce train que j'ai eu
à connaître dans des précédentes
fonctions je j'imagine que le ministre
des Transports
souhaitent aussi pouvoir poursuivre ce
train des primeurs et je voilà je ne
suis pas au courant de la l'avancement
de la procédure sur les deux remarques
sur les courriers
je peux vous décrire le fonctionnement
de du gouvernement français et ses
relations avec la Commission européenne
il se trouve que je n'ai pas eu
d'échanges avec la présidente de la
commission donc c'est votre choix de
voilà de ne pas
pardon
je vous rappelle que je parle sous
serment là voilà donc je pense que je
mesure que quand je vous dis que je n'ai
pas décrit avec la présidente de la
commission je n'ai pas décrit avec la
présidente de la commission
sur l'adaptation des règles sur le fret
ferroviaire enfin je pense que
effectivement personne n'est ne peut se
réjouir de la situation dans laquelle on
se retrouve est-ce que pour autant c'est
le principe même d'une concurrence sur
le fait de ferroviaire qui est en cause
je pense que ça mérite d'être approfondi
il y a autour de nous des pays dans
lequel la part modale du frais de
ferroviaire et sans doute plus
importante que chez nous et voilà dans
un cadre qui est le même pour tout le
monde donc je pense qu'on peut aussi
s'interroger sur l'efficacité de nos
opérateurs et la façon de de renforcer
l'efficacité c'est ce qu'on s'était
forcé de faire en tout cas c'est ce que
j'ai pu
m'employer à faire en tant que ministre
et ensuite ces règles de la concurrence
je pense qu'on est content de les
trouver quand il s'agit par exemple
d'engager une procédure contre Google
seul ou quand la Commission européenne
va se préoccuper des règles de
concurrence avec des fabricants
d'automobiles chinoises donc c'est des
règles qui nous permettent aussi de
protéger nos entreprises
vis-à-vis d'acteurs qui utilisent des
méthodes que nous n'utilisons pas donc
je pense que peut-être franchir un peu
vite une étape de considérer que ce
principe même des règles de concurrence
qui sont en cause je pense que la
trajectoire sur lequel prête SNCF s'est
engagé depuis la réforme ferroviaire
nous montre que c'est possible de
d'assurer une exploitation équilibrée
que c'est possible de regagner de
l'activité et voilà je pense que ce
qu'on peut tous souhaiter c'est que
cette dynamique se poursuive et que le
frais de ferroviaire en général se
redéveloppent conformément à l'objectif
de doublement de la part modale que j'ai
que j'ai évoqué
merci même la première ministre pour
cette audition et d'avoir débordé un
petit peu sur le temps qui était prévu
pour celle-ci merci beaucoup